- A quick caveat before
we get started here,
I do not want Smarter
Every Day to be observed as
a channel that glorifies weaponry.
I am just fascinated by fluid dynamics,
ballistics, optics,
mechanics, aerodynamics.
All this stuff is just fascinating to me.
And I am hard-pressed to
find one singular thing
that I can study that wraps
all these physical phenomenon
into the perfect Venn
diagram that tickles my brain
quite like firearms.
So, that's why you'll see me
studying firearms so often
and I hope you realize that
I'm doing it as intelligently
and respectfully as I can.
That being said, I've
made some observations
in the last episode and
I've learned some stuff.
And I've also decided to
push it a little further
by studying suppressors.
So, let's look at this and
try to get smarter everyday.
First, let's revisit what we
learned in the last episode.
Using a phantom camera with a
clever photography technique
called Schlieren, which is
German for streak by the way,
we observe that the
supersonic bullet creates
an angular shot cone and
the angle of that cone can
be used to determine the mach number.
We also learned from
Dr. Konigstrasse at UAH
that a bullet travelling
in the transonic regime
can create supersonic flow around it
because the air has to speed up
and rush around the outside
of the surface of the bullet.
This is a connection I
didn't make at the time
but we've all see these awesome pictures
of a fighter jet with this
cone of vapor behind it,
this is totally why that happens.
The jet is flying along
in the transonic regime
just like that bullet and
just like the normal shockwave
that occurs on the side
of the subsonic bullet
that's happening on the jet.
And it does two things, number one,
it makes this cone of
vapor form on the jet
and number two, it makes
me all tingly inside.
Okay, so I think we have
a good understanding
at this point of shockwaves
created by a bullet itself.
You may have heard someone talk
about the crack of a bullet
as it passes, that's
created by this shockwave.
But if you think about
the bang of a gunshot,
it's all those rapidly expanding gases
out the front of a muzzle right?
So it's time to hone in
on that area right there
and study that with super schlom,
super slowmo suppressor
Schlieren, there you go.
It's hard to say.
In a past episode of Smarter Every day
I asked a company to fabricate
a see-through suppressor
so we could see the flame front propagate
through the baffles and try to
understand what was going on.
That was effective in showing
what happens on the inside
of their particular suppressor design
but what I wanna see
is exactly what happens
on the outside of the suppressor,
after all, that's where all the noise is.
Here's my friend Coop firing his rifle
chambered in 300 blackout, both
suppressed and unsuppressed.
I want to show you a full
minute of slow motion video
because I believe it does
the best job of explaining
the physics of what's going on.
On the left we have a suppressed weapon
and on the right we have the
same weapon unsuppressed.
When they're first fired
you can see straight away
that the weapon on the right
seems to have a larger,
dirtier blast but after four milliseconds
there doesn't seem to
be any more shockwaves,
we're just venting the
exhaust gases at that point.
The weapon on the left,
however, is still chugging away.
It's like this initial
blast is bouncing around
on the inside of the suppressor
and just a little bit of the gases
are being leaked out
with every reverberation.
(gunshot echo)
Watch what happens next though.
On the right, the echo from
the unsuppressed weapon
is huge and very distinct.
You can see how powerful and singular
that initial blast was
by how sharp the echo is when it returns.
Imagine that echo entering your ears,
meanwhile you can still see
that the suppressed weapon
is dissipating that
acoustic energy slowly.
This is like the clearest
example I can show
of that energy being
dissipated differently.
On the right, the unsuppressed version,
the whole thing's over in
a millisecond and a half
but on the left, the same acoustic energy
is dissipated over 15 milliseconds.
That is a direct comparison showing you
that it almost acts like
a capacitor in a circuit,
it's like, slowly filtering
the energy as it exits.
Anyway, that energy dissipation
does not come for free.
Suppressors heat up very, very quickly.
All that thermal energy is captured
because it doesn't dissipate
away from the weapons.
So the problem with suppressors is
if you fire enough rounds through 'em,
they heat up very, very fast
and they can cause malfunctions
and even damage to the weapon.
Now let's look at subsonic ammunition
being fired from a suppressor.
This is absolutely fascinating.
Okay first observation.
The first thing that leaves the
suppressor is unburnt powder
and look at that, there's
little baby shockwave,
they're supersonic.
Now whether this is gunk coming loose
from previous shots, or
whatever, I don't know
but it's clearly supersonic.
Second, did you see
that little vortex ring
poot out the end?
Okay, here we go, bullet time.
We know this is a subsonic round
so we're expecting normal shockwaves
on the sides of the
bullet but look at that.
They're not there until the bullet
is several inches away from the muzzle.
It is crazy to think about how complicated
this flow environment
is but it's really fun
to make these observations
and try to figure it out.
This episode of Smarter
Every Day is sponsored
by Hello Fresh.
Hello Fresh is a meal kit delivery service
that sends ingredients
to your house in a bag
and you get a little instruction thing
and you go through and
you get to make food
at your house that you
wouldn't normally cook.
It's a subscription
service, we can pause it
if we go out of town.
It really works for us.
Is that, what are you doin' right now?
Does it say use your hands?
- No it didn't, it just says to mix.
- Have you ever eaten a jalapeno?
- No.
- Today's the day buddy.
- Mummy's gonna have her burger
without jalapenos (laughs)
- You can't deviate from the recipe.
- Yeah, yes I can
(laughter)
- Hello Fresh is America's
number one meal kit service
and right now it's coming
in at about 6.99 a serving
which is really, really affordable
so you get to try new food
you get the stuff sent to your house
so you don't have to worry about shopping.
That's your favorite part, right?
- Absolutely!
- You don't have to like...
- I don't have to shop.
- (laughs) Awesome.
Get started with six meals free
by going to HelloFresh.com
and using the promo code
smarter60 for a total of 60 dollars off.
That's two free meals in each
of your first three boxes.
Big thanks to Hello Fresh for
sponsoring Smarter Every Day
and for making this happen.
I really like it when this happens
and yeah, give it a shot.
I think you'll dig it with
your family, it works for us.
What are these little squirrely things
that come out of the suppressor?
- Okay, so what you're seeing here
on this blackout cartridge
is your seeing unburnt
propellant leaving the
muzzle before the bullet goes
and so for 300 blackout
optimally you get complete
burnout around 9 1/2 to ten
inches of barrel length.
So this is a 10.2 inch barrel length
so we're right on the threshold of burning
all the propellant out before
the bullet leaves the muzzle.
- But look, there was a
supersonic piece of powder
- Yeah there is.
- You see that?
- Whoa!
- This is insane, we're just
like, learning important stuff.
Alright, well that was delightful,
what did we learn John? (laughs)
- Propellant outruns bullets sometimes.
You may have grains of propellant
that exit the muzzle faster
than the bullet, supersonically.
- That's crazy, and there's
a shockwave on those grains
of propellant
- Exactly!
- That's uh, never
would have thought that.
- Neither would I.
- I hope this episode
earned your subscription.
You can also click the bell to be notified
any time I upload
something, or not, whatever.
You're a smart person, you
can make your own decisions.
I'm Destin, you're
gettin' smarter every day.
Have a good one.